so we're right in the middle of a really
interesting confrontation within the
Republican party this isn't normal this
isn't typical former president Donald
Trump has endorsed David Perdue in the
Republican Georgia gubernatorial primary
on the other hand Trump's own vice
president Mike Pence has endorsed
Purdue's opponent Brian Kemp the
incumbent in that very same Georgia
gubernatorial Republican primary today
tonight we will hopefully know the
results of that election it's not
looking good for David Perdue meaning
it's not looking good for Donald Trump's
endorsement but the part I want to focus
on today because we'll have those
results tomorrow is the increased
escalation and tension and attacks
between Donald Trump and Mike Pence most
of it by the way coming from Trump in
the direction of Pence yesterday Donald
Trump appeared on the real America's
Voice show outside the Beltway it's a
completely unhinged delusional show but
a very manic sounding Trump flipped out
on Mike Pence in this hysterical
interview let's take a look at this and
remember this is not normal and Trump
seemingly turning on almost everyone
common a move of narcissists as soon as
people are no longer useful to you or
loyal to you or willing to do whatever
you tell them to do you turn on them
take a look
at me he had a great opportunity and all
he had to send it back to the
legislatures now remember
Trump continues to insist that Mike
Pence should have and could have
rejected the Electoral results on
January 6 2021 and say States each of
you decide each of you decide who
actually won in your state now
unfortunately for Trump Pence couldn't
do that there's actually no real
mechanism the states had already said
here are our votes it's delusional but
Trump continues to attack Pence for it
because when you had all of that
ammunition when you had all of those
things being said about the election and
you had all of the proof that Peter
Navarro and others many others were
talking about it would have been very
easy to send it back and have them come
back so I'm very disappointed at what uh
at The Stance he took but that's his uh
you know we're we're a country it was
very interesting they said he had no
choice but in the meantime they go and
try and change the law so we can't do it
so that means he did have a choice so
we'll have to see we'll have to see what
it all happens but all I know is this
our country has probably never been
worse than it is right now I think we're
in the greatest danger ever of a nuclear
war I would have never thought that
would have happened we're in the
greatest danger of a nuclear war where
it's just so as you can see the the
question was about the possibility that
Mike Pence will run against Trump and
Trump's he he just can't stay focused on
one thing he's talking about nuclear war
he's talking about the impossibility of
what he wanted Mike Pence to do but the
important thing is he essentially at
this point has completely turned on his
own former vice president that's not
normal great danger we're not arrested
affected country anymore so get out
there so important this is a very very
big election that's coming up and by the
way on respected country this is not a
matter of of my opinion it's a matter of
global opinion but it's not a matter of
my opinion
every serious Global study of America's
reputation Around the World shows that
since Trump left and Biden came in
respect for the United States has
increased in just about every country
not every country I think Russia did
prefer Trump uh but just about every
country Trump's just wrong
this is going to be big stuff so David
Perdue just work hard David work hard
we're gonna have a big day tomorrow John
Gordon also Jody Heist Patrick Witt and
you know what you have to get out there
and just vote for every single one
including Jake Evans because Jake Evans
is going to do a fantastic job so good
luck everybody yeah Mr President Just
One Last Thing uh I I just want
everybody to know I never said this to
you publicly but the worst thing Mike
Pence did you on January 6th is not
share that fake legal opinion he had
with either you or Pat Sipple on the
White House legal counsel he had it this
is Peter Navarro by the way Trump's
former economic advisor a lunatic in his
own right duty to you sir as
commander-in-chief he had a duty to this
country he had to do the people of
America to show that flawed legal
opinion he did not do that instead he
stuck the knife not in your back but in
your chest and for that nobody in this
country should consider my has to be
anything other than but retired all
right wow uh guys this is this is
outrageous this is this is bizarre we
you you don't see stuff like this and
the real question and my hope is that
the answer is yes is will this Rift
ultimately work to
hurt the Republican voters in the sense
of will they stay home will they say
well I don't know I mean Pence is
endorsing this person but Pence is bad
according to Trump but Trump is good
according maybe I'll just stay home I
don't know that's that's my interest in
this isn't it being bad for Republicans
we got one new poll about 2022 yesterday
that doesn't look good for Republicans
let's see if it continues and ultimately
we will know what happens in November
one of our sponsors is toodaloo the
plant-based trail mix that's delicious
and climate conscious it's hard for me
to pick my favorite thing about toodaloo
the sweet and savory flavors are great
toodaloo regenerates 100 square feet of
polluted Farmland with every purchase
and gives to causes that are fighting
plastic pollution every bag has 35 grams
of plant-based proteins there's no
refined oil or processed sugars or
artificial flavors the stuff I try to
avoid it's not in there you can
pronounce all of the ingredients I've
been snacking on toodaloo regularly at
home while I'm working my favorite
flavor is the spicy Citrus raw nuts
pumpkin and flower seeds Apple pineapple
chickpeas with a spicy lemon lime kick
you can also get barbecue chocolate
clusters coffee one of my favorites is
maple brittle listen guys my roots are
in New England of course Maple it's
delicious no ingredients to feel guilty
about it's just a great snack and it's a
company that's doing good things for the
planet and they support our show so go
to toodaloo.com Pacman use the code
Pacman for five dollars off the link is
down below